[Music]
all right guys it's finally time to talk
about it
what's up sex game
but only because it has to do with
crypto
yes i know about this [ __ ] dude what do
you know what do you say like a week ago
um you know on coin market cap one of
the top three coins that just popped
like a [ __ ] it was in like times
500 plus or whatever right percent
it was the squid game coin and i looked
at that and i was like who the [ __ ]
who's the idiot that's buying this [ __ ]
and i was like
you guys bought it no i wish there was a
lot of people buying it though really
okay well i
i don't know if you cashed out good for
you but i was like they couldn't really
cash out you couldn't that's the game oh
my god and there was like what happened
okay so pretty much same thing uh uh
people started getting really really
hyped somebody made a squid token a cold
squid on the ticker and then people
started putting money to it and it was
on like another platform on a website
that had like misspelled [ __ ] no white
paper no no nothing that's all crypto i
think it was a sharp website though the
website was decent like they had like a
whole road map of what they're gonna do
and all this [ __ ] but the thing is
people who are putting money in were
bringing up the price action of the coin
but nobody could withdraw and they were
actually it was probably like four or
five days of like little articles that
were coming up like people are getting
upset because they can't withdraw and
like anybody [ __ ] knows those
situations is usually like
that looks like a rug pull what's that
other meme coin that um had something
less obvious but did the same thing but
like there's a bunch it was like a
pyramid scheme type deal yeah it was a
bond yeah big
was at least a pyramid scheme where
somebody could cash out
and then they ran with it
there's a bunch of them though there was
even a
health one ehc or something earlier this
year as well
big stuff but anyways point is uh yeah
so a very very common term called rug
pullings where like the creators of the
founders of the thing will eventually
just take all the money that have been
injected and bought and balance yeah it
took like what three mil or something
huh uh it's it's anywhere from two point
nine to three point four million uh
is it technically illegal oh absolutely
yeah oh yeah but it's also technically
technical like you yeah you can't find
and it's and it's like untraceable or
it's hard to show so they probably won't
get caught
no they probably will get caught because
it's all on a blockchain right so you
can see all these transactions happening
you can see
i mean they'll they'll find it trust me
there's forensic blockchain analysts now
what's illegal about it
what's it it's probably gaming fraud
what what what if my my description and
what i tell you it is is the same as
what's going on
the hey we're committing fraud i don't
think i don't think it works it doesn't
work that way yeah i don't know no
because you're still committing a crime
even if like that's like me saying like
hey bart bart's signed a contract where
he's gonna be my slave
and it's like well that doesn't work no
i think that kind of does work if it's a
volunteer no no no no it's still like
against our laws that's the thing you
can contract innately i mean it can't be
innately illegal you can't say mike you
can kill me but yeah i can't do that but
a volunteer and a slave aren't that far
off like i'm sure there's some semantics
we could work on i just wonder how i
could you could pay me for an asset that
sucks and i give you my money
i mean
i know you're getting digital space it
just seems so great yeah well it's like
this with penny stocks too i mean you
could you could argue that i think we
have to go ask the sec what the what the
rules are all that [ __ ] isn't rules
that's what's going on with ripple and
everything else right like the rules are
so great in this space yeah but that's
also what makes it so attractive because
like
all you see in the greyness right all
people especially dollar signs baby
everybody's just like wait if you buy
shiba you're going to become a
millionaire so everybody once it goes to
a one dollar yeah be a billionaire guys
so people put money in but they don't
think to themselves that the reason why
people are becoming millionaires because
a million people are losing money some
of this happened in the uh uh content
creator space a lot of it oh yeah you're
about phase
you guys know what phases yeah phases of
gaming work i think a couple of their
members or owners or something um
phase clan yeah yeah and they're huge
now you know they started like this
little gaming nerd [ __ ] in like 2008 or
whatever but now they're like they're
like the biggest yeah their merch is
huge like they're killing it um
they
either got paid sponsorship or paid
ownership in a crypto to
pump it to their audience that's right
and then they got rug pulled out
and it was like kind of a scam and it is
so public right because these content
creators get millions of hits on their
youtube videos every day but i don't
know if they went to jail or nothing
was it was it their doing or yeah they
pulled or they got pulled yeah are they
no no no they're supposedly in on it i
don't know details i didn't read that
but i'm pretty sure they were in on it
they either got paid straight cash to
promote it or or they got paid ownership
in the company that pulled so then they
got cashed out well squid pumped from my
god it was like 50 cents or some [ __ ]
and then it went all the way like 13
bucks in one day and then it went all
the way up to 2 000.
2860 was the highest
thousand dollars
you're just sitting there trying to
click trying to [ __ ] transfer she
lost like 30k on it and like for
spending yeah well so here's all this
[ __ ] happening in real time it was why
in this article right here it says
squeaking crypto token cost one shanghai
investor his life savings of 28k after
the coin plunged near zero
dude imagine like the stories that and
and i think we also say this we also say
this because we we talk about a lot of
crypto on and off camera in general so i
i know a lot of people um that don't do
their own research and just kind of hear
of the of the amazing stories right
that's my style yep me too yeah right
you amazing conservative person who's
gonna whip all our asses um but the
point is it's like people people hear
about all these
magical stories where people become
millionaires people become
multi-millionaires overnight so you got
a situation like this where you're like
massive cultural phenomenon of the thing
like squid game add that to a massive
social cultural phenomenon of something
like crypto it could be a surefire home
winner yeah you know especially if you
missed a couple other boats so i can
imagine a dude like this puts his life
savings which i think is dumb as [ __ ]
dogecoin that's it they want the pumps
will there be justice though will these
people get their money back ever no [ __ ]
no [ __ ] away we'll get their money back
no the lawyers the lawyers will get the
money or whatever it's all that kind of
same kind of [ __ ] it [ __ ] sucks
but i mean like
this is just gonna keep on happening in
the wild wild west until things get like
uh either fully regulated becomes no
cultural norm the idea is not to be
regulated though right
no but i well no the regulation is
always going to happen it's already
happening it's it's a good thing for the
space to have regulation because it
legitimizes it yeah and it's not like
you regulate the coin it's like you
regulate the way that it's adopted
within your country is all you know what
i'm saying you can't like regulate the
space but you can't control the supply
of the coin which is awesome the problem
that that i have with stuff like this is
it it really dilutes the belief in
crypto in general because people don't
understand that crypto is not this [ __ ]
but they they think that all these coins
are like this right every coin's a [ __ ]
coin except for bitcoin and it's just
not true there's so many protocols being
used so much utility to all this stuff
that people don't know about but they
use bitcoin for fraudulent [ __ ] but so
i mean the us dollars probably used for
drug dealing yeah and you know you find
warehouses of cash in every drug
dealer's uh warehouse dollar in south
america how'd that happen right
it's the best whereas and by the way
there's a public ledger you can actually
track these transactions two wallets you
can find out where people are pulling
money out of the wallets it's all more
transparent than our financial system is
steve it's a scam and you're shilling
out scams steve
try to tell people to buy these coins
dude
my uh my scam group just had another
round of people uh hit the six figure
range so we're doing a rough oh it's
having a lot of time over there i know
it's the [ __ ] bastard but you're not
how do i get on this game can i get this
game group you got you you're a little
late now you're probably a little late
the scams are over
the scans are still gonna happen but as
far as mainstay stuff the i would he got
some good scam stories though did he
yeah you got this my scam stores yeah
yeah the dough [ __ ] you got some dogs
yeah we did it right
you bought some dojo anybody who said
that yeah we did all right means they
[ __ ] smashed three good dudes like
like 500 to 19k
but that's [ __ ]
like you did a good job why didn't you
buy doge that's so amazing uh
it probably was some tick tock [ __ ] like
a year and a half ago hey you held
that's the key to me a lot of people
just let go let [ __ ] go and then they
don't ever reach their potential yeah
and then like just some people like me
hold the bag and watch it climb to the
top and then watch it die that's pretty
good and then it climbs and then dive
and i never cash out i like the meme
scam idea but i'm like pseudo real i see
like mark cuban talking about i'm like
all right like that guy's not a complete
[ __ ] you know you see elon talking
about like he's not a complete [ __ ]
like something's going on you know if we
use that for like our tipping service or
whatever we might end up like they talk
about we're gonna maybe well what do you
what do you think about the fact that
they can print as much doge as they want
yes i mean then it's the usd and you can
get rich on usd i know the risks yeah
yeah same idea
it's kind of a little wacky a little bit
not as smart as steve uh but i'm not
completely but it's not that i'm smart
you're uh well red real reverse i know
my [ __ ] but
but no but
so with stuff like this you know and i'm
not saying that anybody here doesn't but
stuff like this i don't know it's what
makes it it breaks my heart a little bit
yeah because it makes it everyone it
makes people go oh no see i told you
crypto was a scam you got to run away
from me let's educate the people steve
give them like one uh a coin uh that
like does something like the youth and
the utility of it say like in basic
terms yeah i'm wearing the hat [ __ ] uh
no but they're so luna luna tara luna
you can do so much with it including
there's a savings protocol called anchor
where you can actually take forget the
risk of crypto where people go like oh
my god i'm worried about the volatility
well you can actually have a stable coin
called ust it's the only decentralized
stable coin by the way that exists and
it just mimics the dollar right it well
it's stable with the dollars the
currency the value of the dollar the
only thing it would go up and down is
inflate inflation or not or whatever
well yes but it has a unique mechanism
it has its own federal reserve baked
into it basically so for every one
dollar of ust
um that gets generated one dollar of
luna gets burned so it's constantly
maintaining the peg that's how they hold
the value of the dollar but also the ust
is always pegged to the dollar yeah so
it won't change that's what i'm gonna
save your money
so you lose money to the dollar as well
so it's the same same it's the same
value and as the terror ecosystem grows
more protocols use ust and so the more
ust that gets generated the more luna
gets burned so it's that's why luna's
been pumping out performing the market
that's why the entire time me and joe
been in it since like [ __ ] forever
because
when i read about that that's what i've
been looking for in crypto so you're the
only one winning though right because
i'm broke as [ __ ]
fair
we're trying to keep that we're trying
to keep that brand up
[Music]
[Music]
you